five you just go bishop d1 exactly well  the bishop g5  probably we take first and and play  bishop d1  oh that is disaster that is  absolutely disastrous so magnus is still  pushing wow  bishop g5 on the board did peter just  miss this oh  he's going to go bishop d1 he's going  and he finds it he plays it he plays  your line danny you called it  oh that's gone that's very strange i  mean unless there was nothing  better but i find that hard to believe  no i think he just missed this i think  he was thinking about only knight takes  d6  uh there's just no way otherwise that he  would have a lot of rights  that's that's why he basically just  assumed knight d6 was  was coming and and overlooked  uh bishop d1 and he's resigned oh that's  a pity actually  peter was let's just have a look at that  because um  well